(slow electro music)
- I'm playing the long
game. I always have.
It's why a lot of you have
good relationships with me.
I see you at different
places, I know who you are,
I care, I interact with you, like,
life is simple. The truth wins.
You may be confused 'cause times are tough
and the media and there's
always issues in this country
and we got flaws and all that stuff.
You're more than welcome
to look at the pessimistic
aspects of society and life.
I choose to in my 80, 90
years hopefully on earth
to understand that I
got to be a human being
which if you wanna talk
about big data and math
the rarity of actually
becoming a person is insane.
400 trillion to one. I just
want everybody to hear this.
This is the reason I'm happy 24/7, 365
for the rest of my life.
400 trillion to one.
The odds of becoming a human being.
That's the only way to think about it.
Like, what the fuck is
the matter with people?
In the most back row, it's
you don't deserve to be here.
Like, and I like to use the word deserve
because that makes it, like...
It's ridiculous. Like, it's ridiculous!
The whole thing's ridiculous!
Yeah, you know, I just, I'm
gonna struggle to the day I die
of allowing yourself to
look a glass half empty.
I understand it's DNA and
it's wiring and, you know,
if you grew up with a mother
who's extremely negative
it's a really tough
situation to break out of.
It's just proven. I've understood.
You grow up in a tough town, I get it.
There's a couple of issues with that.
Number one, nobody cares.
I kind of literally want
people to pull over right now.
I want you to look at that mirror,
the rear-view mirror right?
That's what it's called?
- Yeah.
Thank you. And while you look
at it, you need to understand
if you look at it, it's your fault.
- What do you mean?
- Everything in life is on you.
That's the big punchline.
Like, everybody's got stuff.
The problem is nobody cares.
And once you understand that nobody cares
and you're complaining to empty air,
you start going in a little
bit of a different direction.
And yeah, I mean, I try to, I
like putting out positivity.
What's happening right
now is the small minority
of people that are mad and
angry and hateful and dark
are much louder than
the big percentage of us
that are happy and excited and feel great
and because the way technology works,
they are much louder than
they've ever been before.
And so I feel like as somebody who's got
full of bright light and happiness,
that I need to start getting
louder about that as well
'cause that's the only
way we're gonna combat it.
(applause)
And you know what?
That right there in real
time is what it's all about
because if that's the
thing that's gonna get
the loudest claps so far
from this conversation,
that's what we need to be focusing on.
I wanna be on the offense of positivity,
not dwell and understand how we got here.
There's only so much I
can do about being happy
and documenting my happy journey.
I'm trying to pressure the other people
that are happy to talk about it too.
I just think we're in a very awkward time.
I think it's rubber necking and it's just
the way it is, right?
We pay more attention to the
negative than the positive,
it's just how I feel about the world.
Like, I think human beings
are the most underrated thing
of all time. When I
think of our capabilities
to eliminate each other
(laughing)
I'm being serious, I know
it's kind of a weird place
to go but, like, the fact
that we're still here
we are hard-wired in a way
that allows us to protect
each other in a net game.
Negativity's a lot easier to
sell, that's why it's working.
Like, what I do for a
living is much harder.
I'm trying to win on positivity,
which is the hardest sell.
I feel more responsibility than ever,
as somebody who is happy
and wants other people
to be happy genuinely
... to get louder, so
it's an interesting time
in our country's history
and just in human society.
If you leave with anything from any of us,
please, please take on the
sense of responsibility
that if you've got good and you feel good,
to start sharing that content as well
because the world needs more of it.
(applause)
(electro music)